we live in an age of self-driving
vehicles robots that work alongside us
okay go and we rely on seemingly
omniscient digital assistants tomorrow
in San Francisco it'll be funny
advances in algorithms sensors and
automation technology stand to upend
nearly every aspect of modern life from
work robots are coming out of their
cages to healthcare pigmented lesion
benign and even how we think of
ourselves as a tool
artificial intelligence might extend
human skills or it might make them
obsolete your kitchen knife can be used
to make great dinners it can be used to
kill somebody and it's up to you to make
that choice ai is a tool just like this
except it's a mental tool so how did we
get here and where we go as early as the
1940s the first modern automation began
to show up in factories computers were
still decades away from becoming
personal but by the late 50s and early
60s computer scientists were already
trying to figure out the big question
will robots make our lives better or
will they replace us entirely on one
side was John McCarthy with artificial
intelligence or AI you know it was
roughly the study of a set of
technologies that would sort of mimic or
replicate human human capabilities
whether they were intellectual or
physical on the other side was Doug
Engelbart's idea of intelligence
augmentation or IA and that sort of led
to the things that would become the
internet and personal computing so you
have these two philosophies and it's
interesting they sort of form both a
dichotomy and a paradox if you extend
the human in an AI a sense away
intelligence augmentation you need fewer
humans or you can just replace them
outright robots and thinking machines
have long been a science fiction fantasy
but by the 1960s they were actually
becoming a reality at Fri we are expert
running with a mobile robot we call him
shakey a wobbly incredibly slow reality
the first real effort to build an
autonomous machine that could move and
reason and act in its environment was
shaky which was a project proposed by a
physicist whose name was Charlie Rosen
at SR I in 1966 he persuaded the
Pentagon by telling them that they could
work on a prototype of something that
might do reconnaissance or be a guard at
certain point they asked them how many
guns in like carrying say both 2 3 how
many didn't need while shakey never
carried guns it did mark the beginning
of a new era of computer science it was
important because it was a platform on
which the algorithms would later be used
by self-driving cars the kinds of things
that you use in your smartphone there
was an algorithm called a star that was
a navigation algorithm is that sort of
granddaddy of the way we get around with
our smartphones and I think importantly
to that the first work on speech
recognition that was significant was
done and shaky because they were looking
for some way to interact with the
machine since the days of shaky
computers have advanced remarkably in
their ability to think for themselves
advanced AI has beaten humans at their
own games from chess now we come to
watch them too jeopardy
perhaps most tangibly of all cars began
driving themselves 12 years ago the idea
that a computer could drive a car was
completely unthinkable we people felt
something as intuitive and as hard to
even explain as driving a car was
reserved for the human race then the
federal Defense Agency DARPA put on a
self-driving car challenge
Stanford's team led by thrown one by
building Stanley a robot car that drove
itself 132 miles across the desert our
secret ingredient was AI it was machine
learning B we actually trained the robot
to do the right thing back in the day
between it how to varied speed way to
steer steering wheel and so on
since then AI and advanced automation
have exploded dozens of companies are
now testing self-driving vehicles most
of us carrier
smartphones loaded with AI powered tools
and last year deep mines alphago a
neural network beat us at our hardest
game go that kind of proves to me that
basically everything can be done
whatever you say can't be done wait
little Anna can be done AI an automation
promise faster and safer solutions to
humanity's problems I see this world
where all these basic things are so
affordable and so good to us that we can
free our minds to develop a humanity
that's completely unimaginable today but
others warn the jobless future it's not
just about factories and when it is
factories they're becoming far more
advanced but it's also your white-collar
things it's jobs done by journalists and
radiologists while there have been
advances there are still limitations
some of the most cutting-edge autonomous
robots can barely do what a human
toddler can do this is McCarthy's
paradox John McCarthy who was the person
who coined the term AI noted this
originally he liked to put his hand into
his pocket and pull out a dime and you
know that's something we do without any
thought it defies the most sophisticated
robotic arm to this day but what AI an
automation may do could forever change
the world and our place in it for the
next five episodes of robots on us we'll
be exploring how these technologies
could impact everything from how we work
or get around to how we take care of our
bodies to how we think of ourselves as
humans
[Music]